rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message pick good people
over to you Bill Gates in my case I'd
say my best business decisions really
have to do with picking people you know
deciding to go into partnership with
Paul Allen is is probably at the top of
the list and then subsequently hiring a
friend Steve Ballmer and having somebody
who you totally trust who's totally
committed who shares your vision yet he
has a little bit different set of skills
and also acts as a check on you you know
some of the ideas you come up with you
run by them because you know they're
gonna say hey wait a minute yeah you
know have you thought about this and
that and just you know the the benefit
of sparking off of somebody who's who's
got that kind of brilliant it's not only
made it fun but it's really led to a lot
of success so picking picking a partners
is crucial if you want to accomplish
something big with your business then
you need to have a team you just have to
look at any of the people that you look
up to who are your entrepreneurial
heroes who has done what you want to do
these are the people you want to emulate
and be on the same level as nobody did
it alone they didn't do it by themselves
they may be the face but there's a lot
of people underneath them and so if you
want to be able to take that ambition of
yours and turn into something big it has
to be with the team it's also really
important that as you grow
you're not just hiring order takers not
just hiring people to do tasks but
you're hiring people to do projects the
difference is look at this business
charlie that's also as an example for me
to be able to tell somebody on the team
I want to add an extra thousand students
next semester to this business go do
that that's a project versus telling
them exactly what they need to do which
is a task if all you are doing is giving
tasks instead of giving projects and you
will always be the bottleneck because
everybody's always coming to you for
advice and to make the fire
decision all you want is people who get
what you want to do who understand the
mission who will push you and come up
with new ideas because they're experts
at what they do and they can take the
project and run with it that's how you
have ultimate success now at the
beginning it's hard very few companies
whoever their first employee was is
still with the business and it's not
because that was a terrible employee
it's mostly because the entrepreneurs
suck at managing you can't just bring
somebody on and say great here's all my
problems you take care of it now you
know that's a real person you got to
deal with you have to train them you
have to support them you have to manage
them you have to love them you have to
care about their growth all of those
things matter and most people at the
beginning really suck at that because we
don't go to school for that we're not
trained in that where do you learn how
to be a great boss doesn't happen in our
education system
and so you have to develop those skills
and here's the thing that holds a lot of
people back they hire somebody
the first hire doesn't work out and then
what you do is you go back to just plain
small like okay
I can't hire someone it's not gonna work
out so I'm just gonna do it myself and
that can work and you can forever be a
small business with just yourself doing
all the work and it'll be high-quality
output but you'll never be able to do
anything really big because your time is
limited you only have certain amount of
hours every single day
don't let that first failure that first
hire not working out prevent you from
continuing the process from hiring again
just like chances are whoever you first
dated is probably not the person you
married sometimes it works out in this
great but most of the time it's not and
so just because you kiss somebody and
that relationship didn't work out it
doesn't mean you throw in the towel and
say I'm never gonna get married it's
never gonna work out I'm just gonna live
by myself my entire life it's not how we
think but for some reason in
entrepreneurship people take that
approach because the first hire didn't
work out now they're never gonna hire
anybody again and so getting over that
hurdle expect the first hire not to work
out even though you're gonna do your
best and every time you're gonna learn
then look to make sure you're hiring
people to do projects and not just tasks
so they can really push you and drive
the mission of the business forward and
it all starts with that mindset
just understanding if you have big
ambition you want to make a mark on your
industry you want to achieve big goals
you can't do it alone
you need great people around you so the
question is 8 today is I'm curious who
is the next person that you need to
bring on board your team not their name
but the position
what's the skill that you need to have
on your business that if they were there
it's going to help catapult your
business forward I'd love to hear from
you and really curious leave it down in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Brandon Slater
Brandon thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word doing
the interview in your youtube channel
and all the love and support around the
book I really really appreciate it man
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events pressive very very very important
do not work in a vacuum do not work in a
vet right you may be either filmmaker
and doing something wrong but you have
to surround yourself with trusted people
you have to you know you get so immersed
in your work you will everybody does you
get so immersed in your work I guarantee
you you will you will not be able to see
the forest from the trees frankly you'll
be stunning the pine needles and worry
about them and you need someone to help
you back up and take a look at the
forest and see where things are working
or not working and you need to surround
yourself with people whose judgment you
trust and they can be brutally honest
with you
and you have to be able to look showing
as an artist showing unfinished work to
people is really difficult is really
hard it always is hard it always will be
hard it never gets any easier but you
have to do you all know that there are
so many details involved in what we do
and so many individuals involved in what
we do so a great chef is really
supported by so many others tonight so I
think what makes a
chef is surrounding yourself with those
of like-mindedness
with a common vision common goals and in
many ways are much smarter than you are
remember that always work with people
that are much smarter than you are the
only way to really get better is to is
to play with those who who can teach you
and be better so what I've tried to do
with my entire career is surround myself
with talented people observe your
environment at work at school at home
I'm asking you to look at the people
around you purposefully and
intentionally invite people into your
life who don't look like you don't think
like you don't act like you don't come
from where you come from and you might
find that they will challenge your
assumptions and make you grow as a
person you might get powerful new
insights from these individuals if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sends you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details